aujourd'hui je suis venu dénoncer aussi
ce que pensent la plupart des français
et des françaises c'est cette
mobilisation cette monopolisation du
président de la république sur une
chaîne à forte audience est d'abord
orchestré organisé une émission de
télévision voilà qui a été enregistré
dans des conditions inédites aucun
président en exercice n'a plus autant
mettre en scène ce soir ce spectacle
télévisuel qu'on va découvrir donc
c'était l'occasion aujourd'hui de
dénoncer ces manoeuvres et puis de
demander au président de la république
de faire un choix de se déclarer est il
candidat et il président de la
république en tout cas à l'ambiguïté est
de mise et donc c'est le moment de
clarifier les pourtant janvier 2012 je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez nicolas
sarkozy n'était pas encore candidat à sa
réélection mais il avait participé lui
aussi à une émission diffusée sur huit
chaînes tous les présidents français a
finalement et le temps avaient été
décomptés lorsque président nicolas
sarkozy s'était exprimé sur plusieurs
chaînes en janvier 2012 en effet le csa
bd compter son temps de parole en
estimant que ça pouvait mettre en doute
et ça devait rentrer dans le cadre de sa
campagne électorale c'est ce qu'on
demande aujourd'hui via ma question au
gouvernement je voulais aussi sollicité
le csa en leur demandant de bien vouloir
des comptes est aussi le temps parole du
président ce soir comme ça a été le cas
en 2012 avec nicolas sarkozy alors je
disais vous vous êtes directrice
déléguée de la campagne de valérie
pécresse aujourd'hui les sondages se
suivent et se ressemblent un peu pour
votre candidate elle arriverait au coude
à coude de deuxième tour avec emmanuel
macron dans les semaines à venir quels
sont les biens les prochaines étapes de
cette campagne pour valérie pécresse on
est dans une forte dynamique a été aussi
la conséquence de la réussite de
l'organisation de ce congrès elle est
arrivée en tête aujourd'hui l'unité qui
était le maître mot de cette campagne se
poursuit l'ensemble des candidats on
forme une équipe de france et puis
l'ensemble des élus de france et des
français et des françaises qui adhèrent
à son projet sont rassemblés derrière
elle donc elle va continuer sur sa
lancée elle s'est pas déclarée candidate
à l'élection il ya quelques jours ça
fait des années qu'elle se prépare avec
un bilan des compétences beaucoup de
force de projets beaucoup de personnes
qui les rassemble donc on va continuer à
aller dans les territoires puisque cette
campagne va se faire non seulement à
droite mais aussi dans les territoires
c'est là que de nouveaux déplacements ce
ce que vous ailleurs un des déplacements
il ya les déplacements chaque jour
partout en france et dans d'autres
territoires également l'objet c'est
d'être présent partout et d'être à
l'écouté des français comme elle a
toujours su le faire en quatre de ses
membres comment on rassemble petite
dernière question comment rassemble des
lignes aussi
irréconciliables aux difficiles à
réconcilier comme jean christophe
lagarde et laurent wauquiez comment en
effet cohabiter ont fait cohabiter
différentes sensibilités quand on a une
personnalité une candidat ou une
candidate qui s'est justement rassembler
les différentes personnalités je crois
qu'aujourd'hui si l'ensemble de nos
adhérents les républicains se sont
rassemblés derrière valérie pécresse
séquelles à cette forme de consensus
donc je n'ai aucun doute dans le fait
qu'elle réussira à réunir autour de la
table des centristes une ligne plus à
droite elle a fait le choix aussi de
faire cette campagne aux côtés d'eric
ciotti ski voilà ce qui révèle les
différents courants de pensée qu'il y
aura dans cette candidature qui
représentera la droite et le centre
merci beaucoup mais dans la matrice
merci d'avoir un 1er mai question
voilà pour cette réaction d'alexandre
abord que frontin la directrice déléguée
de la campagne de valérie pécresse autre
réaction après cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
autre réaction au micro de steve
jourdain celle de patrick kanner le
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
oui avec patrick kanner bonjour bonjour
emmanuel macron s'exprimera ce soir dans
une interview enregistrée ce que comme
la droite vous demander à ce que le
temps de parole du chef de l'état soit
décompté
[Musique]